So before I run this program, let me share with
you my hypothesis of what will happen when I run this
piece of code. Now one of the first things we are
doing here in this program, is that we're creating an instance
of class child we called it miley_cyrus. As soon as that
line of code runs, the init method inside class child will
get called. The first line within the init method, is this
print statement. So my hypothesis is, that this print statement will
be printed out first in our output. After that
the constructor for the class parent is going to get
called. So the control will move from here up to
here. When the init method for class parent is called,
this statement is going to get executed. So my
hypothesis is that this print statement parent constructor called will
be the second thing that gets printed. Then the instance
variable's last name and eye color will be appropriately initialized.
Once the init method for class parent has successfully
run, the control will come back here. At that
point, the instance variable number_of_toys will successfully get initialized.
So at that point, the init method for class child
is done, which means that the instance miley_cyrus has
been created successfully. Then, the following two print statements which
are trying to print the last name and number
of toys for miley_cyrus will get executed in that order.
Alright, this time let me actually run this piece of code. And there's
my output. And it seems pretty close to what I thought it would
be. Now, I want you to pause the video here for a second,
and I want you to see if the output here matches your hypothesis.